I would love to say that desantis's
dangerous authoritarian Tendencies are
the reason why he's failing in the polls
but Trump has all of those same
authoritarian Tendencies so that's not
actually what it is I I do think that
there is something too the idea of
DeSantis is becoming the reality of
DeSantis and a lot of people don't
really like it so Trump aside DeSantis
is dangerous DeSantis is doing better
against uh Biden than Trump is doing so
in a sense it's probably good for the
left for DeSantis not to do well in the
primary on the other hand DeSantis
bailing
might make Trump's path easier which has
its own downsides in that he may end up
in the general election less weakened
and sort of more ready to go but that a
lot of things are going to happen
between now and when the general
election starts